[Musique]
le grand retour des gilets jaunes ce
samedi en france avec des tensions à
paris des manifestations dans le calme
en province
aucun cas aux ne sera tolérée c'est l
avertissement ce matin du préfet de la
capitale
le ministère de l'intérieur qui a mis en
oeuvre une nouvelle doctrine du maintien
de l'ordre
250 interpellations 147 personnes
placées en garde à vue dans les cortèges
parisiens les grandes figures du
mouvement comme jérôme rodriguez ou éric
drouin
autre soutien des gilets jaunes
l'humoriste jean marie bigard a dû être
exfiltré après des attaques de certains
militants du mouvement
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france
bienvenue dans cette édition entièrement
consacré à cette journée gilet jaune
aujourd'hui le retour dans les rues et
sur les ronds-points de france avec
quelques tensions dans la capitale vous
le voyez aux abords de la place bagram
mais aussi avenue de villiers dans le
17e arrondissement 2 manifestation avait
été autorisée dans la capitale mais loin
des champs elysées et des lieux de
pouvoir
les deux cortèges qui ont ensuite
convergé place de champerret la
dispersion qui s'est fait également dans
le calme aux alentours de 18h bilan 147
gardes à vue deux cent cinquante six
interpellations ont fait le point avec
notre reporter sur place nadège
abderrazak fin de manifestation qui
s'est déroulée plus ou moins en quoi
avec des épisodes de tension quand même
elle a bien commencé dans le calme et
dans la bonne humeur s'était depuis la
place de la bourse à midi donc c'était
calme pendant deux heures à peu près
puis ça a dégénéré avenue de wagram
avenue de villiers ou d'autres
manifestants
d'autres manifestations qui ont été
interdites ont rejoint ce cortège de
cette manifestation qui a été déclarée
en préfecture de police et qui a été
autorisé par les autorités et qui donc a
dégénéré à ce moment là puisque ces
manifestants et bien on voulait ont
voulu détourner le parcours officiel est
déclarée en préfecture de police de
paris ça n'a pas forcément plu aux
dispositifs de sécurité présents sur
place et donc des heurts ont rapidement
eu lieu entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre et le gaz lacrymogènes et coups
de matraques ont répondu aux nombreux
jets de projectiles a lancé à
destination à des forces de l'ordre plus
d'une centaine de personnes ont été
blessées ici des street medic notamment
des gilet jaune et qui ont été prises en
charge donc aux voilà une rentrée
quelque peu sous haute tension qui est
bien des gilets jaunes qui avaient à
coeur de reprendre le chemin des
manifestations je vous propose justement
d'en écouter quelques cents plus on
vient
peut-être y en a beaucoup qui disent
doit cesser et il faut laisser tomber il
faut laisser tomber
mais non faut jamais de ceux tombés faut
absolument continuer à montrer qu'on
n'est pas contente ce qu'il fait n'est
pas normal ce gouvernement n'est pas
l'écrit double du tout voilà c'est pour
ça que je viens et je vais le démontrer
absolument depuis la crise de gilet
jaune il aurait dû avoir un un
référendum
il n'y a jamais eu ce référendum
populaire donc c'est tout simplement dit
ni démocratie pour moi purée et dur nous
on est là les medics pour soigner
policiers et manifestants
et voilà les policiers de du moins de
deux gradés on nous ont pris notre
matériel dont 10 soit on vous donnez
votre matériel sans vous embarque alors
je suis là aujourd'hui parce que depuis
huit jours je suis à la retraite et
quand j'ai vu ce que je vais avoir c'est
une misère un mille euros pour 44 années
de travail mais j'ai fait beaucoup
d'autres manifs en tant que salarié là
pour défendre notre notre vivre et non
notre survivre voilà faut acheter son
air dans un restaurant une terrasse tu
achètes un co cathédrale respirer tu
marches dans la rue tu achètes rien ça
droit d'avoir thomas ce qui l'étouffé
on aura des problèmes tous huit heures
de marche comme ça ils vont avoir
tu vas voir dans un mois ce qu'on va
faire une manif vous allez tomber malade
et moi c'est pourquoi vous tombiez
malade que je me bats où vous l'avez
entendu des gis les jeunes qui sont
toujours déterminés et bien à faire
entendre leurs revendications qui sont
les mêmes depuis le 17 novembre 2018 en
sachet maintenant près de deux ans que
le mouvement a été et crée donc hausse
du pouvoir d'achat plus de justice
fiscale sociale et environnementale et
la mise en place encore une fois du riq
du référendum d'initiative citoyenne
alors cette colère sociale
elle a été amplifiée par la crise
sanitaire liée aux qu'ovide 19 alors
d'après de nombreux manifestants le
gouvernement a mal géré cette crise
sanitaire ils ont notamment évoqué le
scandale lié aux masques en début
d'épidémie un scandale est liée aux
masques puisque à l'époque le
gouvernement est bien affirmé le
contraire d'aujourd'hui que le masque et
bien était inutile et qui ne servait à
rien aujourd'hui la doctrine est à
changer donc on a on a eu au sein du
cortège de nombreux
de nombreuses personnes qui est bien ont
refusé de porter ce masque une poignée
faut le dire mais tout de même il était
présent on voit là beaucoup de gillet
jeunes présents à cette manifestation
pour tenter de donner un
nouveau souffle à ce mouvement des
appels à manifester sur les réseaux
sociaux auxquels ont donc répondu pas
mal de sympathisants aujourd'hui jérôme
rodriguez qui a perdu un oeil lui au
cours de précédentes manifestations
avaient appelé à la désobéissance civile
écoutez le pour lui les gens n'ont pas
peur du coc vide
ils ont peur des conséquences du comité
on n'a qu'une bâton parce que t'as pas
de masque pas d'une amende parce que
t'as pas de masque c'est ça la réelle
peur maintenant ceux qui ont le plus
peur ces lieux gouvernement c'est
monsieur l'allemand quand on voit
l'arrêté qui l'a mis en place je croyais
qu'on était morts l'usiné dont deux sont
morts c'est halloween aujourd'hui non le
vrai virus aujourd'hui c'est la po jouit
le ventre vide au virus pour les
français jérôme rodriguez dont les
propos sur les policiers qualifiés de
nazis ont valu la prise de distance de
l'humoriste jean marie bigard pourtant
soutient lui aussi de la cause mais
lorsqu'il a voulu se joindre aux
manifestations ce matin il a été pris à
partie vous voyez par certains
manifestants qui estiment que jean marie
bigard m'a donc plus sa place au sein du
mouvement
il a été sommé de quitter le
rassemblement et a même dû être exfiltré
des lieux à moto écoutez le
[Applaudissements]
je suis là pour dire que jusqu'au je
suis solidaire avec les jets jaune bien
sûr je suis jamais désolidariser dj les
jeux vont se désolidariser de des propos
de jean brouillette
on lui doit une belle partie de cette
mère de jean baudrillard je me tenais
pas être conspué comme ce à quoi je
mérite pas ce à quoi je suis le plus
grand défenseur des gilet jaune
j'ai les couilles d'avoir gardé ce même
sentiment de bulles début est là
je comprends pas trop pourquoi
autre figure historique du mouvement
présent aujourd'hui à paris éric drouin
qui ne souhaite plus représenté le
mouvement eric drew et qui a tout juste
été relaxé en appel hier il avait été
accusé d'avoir organisé des
manifestations illégales
pour lui les landais début n'est plus là
écoutez plus il y aura des décisions du
gouvernement qui sont dans le sens où on
appelait on appelait moins en moins de
droit et plus aura de gens dans la rue
c'est sûr ça va revenir quoi qu'il
arrive avec le co vide comme on la crise
a été gérée tout ça tu auras pas une
révolution n'y aura pas de changement là
c'est trop gentil encore faut vraiment
que ça pète un bon coup et qu'on marque
pour remettre tout en place
sinon il y aura pas de changement je
suis pas je suis pas dans ce pas
d'accord trop avec les freins ce qui
continue à être un peu leader dg les
jaunes qui déclare les manifestations il
ya différents ya plein de manifestations
dans paris on n'arrive même pas à se
mettre d'accord sur une seule un point
rendez vous dès que le gouvernement
annonce un lieu interdit tous les gens
se rétracter vont dans des trucs
autorisée c'est bête mais au début dé
gilet jaune c'était pas ça on n'avait
pas peur de venir et va peut-être
d'affronter les forces de l'ordre parce
qu'elle nous réponde et dès le début
quoi il n'y avait pas que des gilet
jaune parmi les manifestants aujourd'hui
des patrons de discothèques très
durement touché par la crise puisque ils
ne peuvent toujours pas ouvrir leurs
établissements étaient présents écoutez
les à l'heure actuelle nos qu'elles sont
en train de se vider on a déjà 80 deux
entreprises qui ont déposé le bilan et
300 qui risque de le déposer
fin décembre à ce rythme là au mois de
mars avril 25 à 40 mille emplois seront
sur le carreau nous ce qu'on aimerait
c'est pouvoir rencontrer rapidement
monsieur grise et on l'attend son retour
pour négocier davantage dead est une
ouverture de nos établissements
mais qu'on soit aidée financièrement
parce que pour l'instant entre ce qui
nous était promise
et ce qui tombe dans nos caisses et à
fausser c'est à dire que moi pour ma
part on ag pas eu encore d'être j'ai eu
trois fois 1500 euros depuis le mois de
mars et je n'ai pas eu de salaire ou non
tenues je me sens un citoyen qui n'a
plus à qui tu ne peux plus travailler
c'est à dire que à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus travailler c'est grave
il faut il faut se remettre au travail
pour
m les discothèques au travail faut les
laisser pouvoir faire tourner l'économie
laissez-nous collecter de la tva laissez
nous payer nos salariés
c'est ce qu'on demande pouvoir
travailler comme tous les français
présente également dans les cortèges des
syndicats ou des personnalités
politiques de la france un soumise
notamment à l'instar du député du nord
qui est venu soutenir les gilet jaune
pour lui leurs revendications sont plus
légitimes que jamais dans ce contexte
sanitaire et écouter adrien caténaire à
écouter la preuve a priori et sont
toujours là et dans cette rentrée qui
est une crise sanitaire sur laquelle
débouche un véritable tsunami social
les revendications clés gilet jaune
porté ya quelques mois sont encore plus
prégnante aujourd'hui voyez par exemple
ce plan de relance qui distribue des
milliards aux grandes entreprises sans
contrepartie et à l'heure qu'il est les
jours se suivent et se succèdent avec
les plans de licenciement de grandes
entreprises qui ont bénéficié à plein
des aides publiques savez moi y'a trois
chiffres que j'utilise beaucoup en cette
rentrée avec lesquels on peut pas
relancer une économie en dix ans en
france les dividendes versés aux
actionnaires ont progressé de 70%
investissements productifs
diminué de 5% et le salaire minimum n'a
augmenté que de 12% avec de tels
chiffres
vous ne relancez pas une économie et
pour en parler nous sommes avec serge
federbusch ancien candidat du
rassemblement national à la mairie de
paris
bonsoir serge federbusch merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france qu'elle
quel bilan vous portez quel regard vous
portez sur 7
journée des gilet jaune y at il à un
retour véritablement selon vous là on a
l'impression qu'on prend lui-même et
qu'on recommence d'abord le gouvernement
cherche à nier l'importance quand il dit
qu'il ya mille personnes qui défie le
bon moi j'ai vu beaucoup plus de gens
d'une côté 17e arrondissement et puis
surtout on peut pas prétendre qu'on
interpelle de 150 personnes alors que il
y avait dix personnes au total parce que
ça voudrait dire qu'il est interpellé
une personne sur quatre qui évidemment
impossible donc qu'ils sous-estiment il
y avait un dispositif policier
impressionnant la place de la concorde
et différents quartiers touchés à
l'échangé d'idées et et clé donc je
pense qu'il ya une certaine fébrilité
en même temps les les errements qui gêne
un peu dans l'évolution du mouvement pas
le moment d'origine a continué c'est à
dire qu'on voit effectivement les black
blocks et internet ultra gauchiste
s'infiltrer ce qui arrange le
gouvernement bien entendu où est ce que
je crois c'est que la situation
économique qui est un peu mise sous le
boisseau pour l'instant en cause des
raisons sanitaires et le fait que bon il
ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont aidés
alors pas tout le monde on voit bien
effectivement dans le cas des patrons de
boîte de nuit
mais bon on sait que de toute façon dès
que l'état ne pourra plus faire face à
cette situation et ça viendra quand même
assez rapidement dans les mois qui
viennent on risque d'y avoir lyrique
diamant une vraie résurgence de ce qui
est impressionnant c'est que deux ans
plus tard
ça n'a pas disparu et c'est tout à fait
il est dit dans l'histoire sociale de
ces cinquante dernières années
un mouvement qui dure comme ça depuis ie
depuis deux ans quelles que soient les
circonstances et malgré la crise
sanitaire
alors il ya effectivement d'autres
personnes qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui
aux côtés des gilets jaunes dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire les patrons
de discothèques et personnels de santé
également ccc cette grogne qui couve
est-ce que ça va s'amplifier selon vous
i les aides de l'état certes non révélé
patrons de discothèques ça ne nous aide
pas non plus véritablement entièrement
bâti évidemment l'état n'a pas bon des
moyens un fier il est actuellement à
l'endettement et dans l'impression de
monnaie de singe par la banque centrale
européenne on va avoir des petits
budgétaires qui risquent de date un des
300 milliards qui est pratiquement
l'équivalent du montant vous voyez des
dépenses publiques dire qu'on est dans
des circonstances économiques
complètement aberrante aucun ménage
aucune entreprise de continuer à
fonctionner comme ça ça marche
uniquement parce qu'il ya ce pouvoir de
création monétaire ne grâce à la banque
centrale européenne
et ça marchera pas indéfiniment et
l'état ne peut pas venir au secours de
tout le monde de la même manière donc
dès qu'il ya une corporation qui peut se
faire entendre dans le secteur culturel
monter un bon par exemple le sauvetage
des transports en ile-de-france ont les
tarages de l'argent à de l'argent mais
ça ne durera pas et donc il va y avoir
un amendement des mécontentements dans
les mois qui viennent c'est sûr et un
moment ou un autre
l'embrasement pour commenter quand en
fait on sera en particulier à l'automne
ou à l'hiver quand on fait les derniers
feux des vacances et tu te fais ton
disparaîtront je pense que le
gouvernement a conscience de sa lé
pouvoir a conscience de ça et c'est bien
pour ça qu'on avait à faire à ce
dispositif de policiers tout à fait
travail quand on regarde le nombre de
manifestants les certains médecins
certains chercheurs d'ailleurs on
ont critiqué la gestion de la crise
l'aide de la crise sanitaire ils disent
que c'est une gestion de la peur sans
véritablement entrer dans le concret
n'en est dans la gestion cette fille
c'est ce qu'on entendait aussi
aujourd'hui chez certains gilet jaune
les français ne s'y retrouvent pas est
ce que le gouvernement a un discours
alarmiste pour masquer justement tous
ces problèmes économiques qui couvrent
effectivement c'est assez pratique de
voir les gens préoccupés à faire des
tests dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
s'ils sont vraiment utiles ou à porter
des masques qui a évité la mort de son
contrat alors que on sait pas du tout si
c'est utile aux surtout au milieu ouvert
mais bon ça me brûle les esprits ça
détourne l'attention et que ça le
gouvernement bon il est embêté
évidemment par la situation parce que ça
la situation connue du coup et fragile
est mauvaise et ils ne peuvent en aucun
cas rare confiné toute la france parce
que sinon ce serait l'effondrement et
d'un autre côté ils sont des espèces de
10 de diversion avec des petits des
annonces assez alarmiste on annonce
aujourd'hui le nombre de contaminés en
permanence on annonce plus jamais le
nombre de décès alors que c'est tout à
fait différent en mars avril parce que
le nombre de décès est très très faible
par rapport à ce qui se passait il ya
quatre cinq mois donc on a un
gouvernement qui est un peu désemparés
qui essaie quand même de tirer parti de
la situation pour s'en sortir bon bah
c'est normal mais c'est un peu son
capitaine tout ça et là aussi comme pour
la situation économique croit qu'ils
savent plus très bien au niveau
donc soit il va non il reconfirme si
c'est vraiment grave pour confiner à ce
moment là c'est un désastre
et si ça ne l'est pas et bien leur
discours donc anxiogène finalement va
être de plus en plus artificielle et de
mauvaise foi et cela finira par se
retourner contre eux en deux manches
serge federbusch est ce que le pari est
gagné pour les gilet jaune selon vous
aujourd'hui pour marquer justement ce
retour moi je crois que bon ils sont
encore très ils sont encore loin du
compte y avait pas énormément de monde
mais le simple fait qu'il continue le
simple fait qu'il puisse y avoir de
l'anxiété le simple fait que il ya une
libération considérable du nombre de
participants montre qu'effectivement le
pouvoir continuent d'avoir peur
pour des contestataires une victoire
alors il est évident que il ya des
débordements que les attitudes de
certains vis-à-vis du gard est
complètement contre-productif idiote et
toucha le gouvernement est bien
évidement tirer parti aussi mais bon
tout mouvement social a célébré ses bas
et puis ces figures je dirais habib et
ses figures maladroite
merci beaucoup serge federbusch d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france
des manifestations à paris et my
effectivement par quelques tensions dans
le 17e arrondissement avec des jets de
projectiles d'éléments cagoulés contre
des tirs de gaz lacrymogène retour sur
ces face-à-face tendu en images regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vous
non
[Musique]
et dans la matinée le préfet de police
de paris s'est rendu sur les
champs-elysées lieux interdits à la
manifestation didier lallement qui a
déclaré avant la manifestation qu'il ne
pouvait y avoir de chaos
la célèbre avenue des champs elysées où
de nombreux magasins se sont barricadés
didier lallement a salué vous voyez les
forces de l'ordre aux abords de l'arc de
triomphe
il est revenu également sur les la
nouvelle doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
de gérald darmanin écouter au 1er
décembre 2018 c'était plus de 1000 tir
de lbb qui avaient été faits au 1er mai
2019 nous avions réduit ce nombre à 66
de façon permanente nous allons réduire
le nombre de tirs de l bd pour que nous
puissions les superviseurs qu'a décidé
le ministre de l'intérieur rivières
seront en place et aideront à cette
maîtrise à ce bon usage du nbd dans des
conditions normales bien sûr il restera
des cas de légitime défense qui sont
tout à fait important donc ces nouvelles
consignes sont mises en place également
le retrait des gmd a été fait sur
l'ensemble des forces aujourd'hui engagé
des gemmes des anciennes un des grenades
anciennes les nouvelles ont été mises en
place et conformément aux instructions
du ministre de l'intérieur
elles seront utilisés ces nouvelles si
besoin aujourd'hui
après retrait bien sûr des anciennes et
pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
pomart ancien policier du raid police
nationale auteur du livre flic d'élite
dans les cités
bonsoir bruno pomart merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france bon bilan aujourd'hui
pour la police on sait qu'il y avait une
nouvelle doctrine est dictée par gérald
darmanin en tout cas en terme de
maintien de l'ordre
les commerçants en tout cas nous on dit
sur notre antenne qu'ils étaient très
content puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de casse
aujourd'hui qu'en pensez vous bah
écoutez d'abord des propos modérés du
préfet de police qui avait des propos
beaucoup plus fort sur les dernières
manifestations que nous avons connus qui
était ultra violente
là je pense que la nouvelle doctrine qui
a été initiée par gérald darmanin est en
train de porter ses fruits effectivement
alors à même temps effectivement cette
manifestation n'a pas eu le le succès
que caisse côté le moment j légende
évidemment puisque on compte entre 3 et
4000 e voire 5000 manifestants mais je
pense que compte tenu du nombre de
policiers engagés sur ce sur ce
dispositif je pense aux crs évidemment
et aux gardes mobiles en particulier
mais également aux unités des bras 140
oeuvres avaient été mobilisés plus les
compagnies de sécurisation des relations
je pense que le métier de landes a été
fort bien assuré aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'appellations en amont c'est ça la clé
de la réussite
oui oui le pré filtrage qui a été fait
ce matin a été déterminant même temps
pour désarmer certains qui venait
effectivement non pas pour manifester
mais pour en découdre avec les forces de
l'ordre s'étaient c'était évident donc
le travail en amont a été très bien fait
à travers ce prêt filtrage et concernant
le maintien de l'ordre qui a suivi
effectivement ça a été fort bien
maîtrisée parce que les forces de
l'ordre étaient à vendre alors c'était
une journée test pour les gêner jaune
une journée test également pour gérald
darmanin at il réussi le test selon vous
écoutez oui il faut il faut avouer que
ça a fonctionné
il n'y a pas eu de dégradations majeures
comme on a connu sur d'autres
manifestations c'est important et encore
une fois je pense que les effectifs
utiliser l'ont été à bonne escient à
savoir que les bras sont intervenus en
marge des manifestations pour
interpeller les éléments les plus
perturbateurs et ceux qui méritaient
d'être réprimée comme on dit dans ce
cadre là puisqu'ils viennent donc pas
pour manifester mais pour s'affronter
aux forces de l'ombre ce qui est
inadmissible évidemment et encore une
fois le travail des crs et des gendarmes
qui a été exemplaire très professionnel
et je pense que c'est une première pour
gérald darmanin une première
manifestation
je dirais réussi pour pour le
gouvernement qu'est-ce qui fait cette
réussite concrètement est-ce que c'est
là la retenue qu'on demande aux
policiers avant cette manifestation
ce sont les ordres en quelque sorte
qu'ils sont donnés ou est-ce justement
le la doctrine
le fait d'utiliser des grenades de
désencerclement moins dangereuse le fait
d'avoir des superviseurs pour les ailes
bd où le nombre de policiers par rapport
au nombre de manifestants c'est quoi
c'est quoi le concrètement ce qui a
porté ses fruits
de nouvelles doctrines c'est une chose
quant à l'utilisation des grenades de
désencerclement quant à l'utilisation du
lb des comme l'a précisé le le préfet de
police effectivement c'est une c'est une
donne ça comme on dit mais je pense
encore une fois que le nombre de
policiers et le quadrillage qui a été
effectué pour éviter qu'ils aient tous
ces débordements a été bien fait tout
simplement je pense que le même temps
les policiers sont malheureusement
habitués à à tous ces dispositifs et ont
su réagir correctement alors c'est vrai
qu'à alors déchargé effectivement le
nombre de manifestations n'étaient pas
très de manifestants pardon et et
n'était pas très important mais quoi
qu'il en soit je pense que ça a été
menée parfaitement parlée par les unités
de d'intervention qui étaient qui
étaient présentes bon alors il faut
attendre la fin de la soirée parce que
ça a l'air d'un accord de bouger j'ai eu
des des collègues qui sont sur le
terrain encore pour et encore une fois
pour interpeller les derniers même pas
manifestants mais les derniers voyous
qui sont là pour effectivement essayé de
casser et d'essayer de remonter sur les
champs-elysées où sont d'autres secteurs
ces voyous comme vous les appelez ce
sont les fameux un black blocks on a vu
des gens cagoulés effectivement dans les
cortèges
est ce que ces gens là sont
véritablement arrêtés et punis ont pas
écoutés il ya eu plus de 200
interpellations qui ont été qui a été
fait par les policiers donc c'est pas
rien des gardes à vue
en conséquence oui encore une fois ces
éléments là encore une fois ne viennent
pas pour le projet d'humour barre des
mouvements légers mouvements gilet jaune
ils viennent simplement pour casser et
en même temps tout ça évidemment est de
parler les ce mouvement de gilet jaune
qui souhaitait faire passer des messages
évidemment et ce qui est ce qui est
dommageable
évidemment pour pour la société en
général alors on évident dans le cortège
aujourd'hui d'autres personnes un pas
que dd gilet jaune ces personnes dont
les gilet jaune d'ailleurs ont aussi
changé d'attitude
il déclare les manifestations en
préfecture il respecte les tracés selon
vous à part quelques éléments bien sûr
alors les tracés et fictive 1 seront
signés sont fiers d'accord avec la
préfecture de police mais pour avoir
débattu
il ya quelques jours sur une autre
chaîne de télévision avec avec jérôme
rodriguez
effectivement il a eu une réunion avec
la préfecture de police et est le
message que je lui avais fait passer moi
puisqu'on a on a eu un débat quelque peu
houleux par rapport aux propos qu'il a
eu vis-à-vis du gouvernement et en
traitant la police de nazis et en même
temps les propos qu'il a eu à l'encontre
de jean-marie bigard bien il est revenu
un petit peu sur ses positions et
effectivement il ya un dialogue qui
s'est effectuée entre la préfecture de
police et des représentants de cette
manifestation c'est une bonne chose je
pense que à partir du moment où cette
manifestation trouvera un cadre légal
organiser un quart des je pense qu'il
ira vers beaucoup moins de deux
problématiques qu'on a connus sur les
premières manifestations
merci beaucoup bruno pomart pour votre
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes donc
anciens policiers du raid et auteur du
livre flic d'élite dans les cités qui
est paru aux éditions anne carrière
merci
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de votre fidélité sur notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes restez
avec nous
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
auzolle comberge vous avez découvert que
l'imagerie médicale qui était le coeur
de votre métier avait une dimension
artistique me suis aperçu que c'était
l'art qui faisait avancer la science et
la science qui faisait avancer là